whatever they do to up your eye I
don't know how they do it like it's a
lens it was a it's a big soft contact
lens and it's you know and there's a guy
they have to have a guy they have to
have a guy taken in and out I couldn't
do it myself and could you see normally
out of your eye when they put this no
it's just opaque so I was blind and and
one eye I couldn't see out of one eye
and driving the car that was a nightmare
and it was like trying to pull up to the
curb and they'd be like can you get
closer to the curb I'm like I can't see
the curb I can't give me a break
I was like can't see anything yeah
remember that scene where you're driving
the kid took I couldn't get to the curb
I couldn't see anything but you know and
I felt nervous too I have people in the
car with me and stuff like that you know
so I was nervous about it it actually
made me more nervous than practically
anything else I've ever done because of
the eye thing I just was like oh my God
this is going something's going to go
wrong then you're outside in the cold
and they're worried it's going to freeze
to my eyeball so the so the guy has to
keep putting I mean the whole thing was
bizarre it was it was really bizarre